hey everyone this is lucy and today i'll
be talking about how i passed the aws
certified solutions after professional
exam in 2022. if you're new to this
channel my name is lucy and i make
videos all about tech career and life at
aws so if you're interested in seeing
more videos like this please make sure
you click on subscribe down below and
give this video a like so i passed this
exam a couple days ago and i was pretty
happy about it because this has been on
my to-do list for the longest time now
and it's more of a long-term sort of
goal because you really need a couple
months to prepare for it so i wanted to
share how i was able to pass this exam
by sharing my resources advice and also
my exam strategies and experience as
well let's just jump right into it so
this exam is three hours long with 75
multiple choice multi-select questions
and it was a pretty intense exam really
glad i was able to dedicate a couple
months leading up to the exam to really
spend some time doing some direct
preparation so speaking of direct
preparation what i used was two main
resources first of all i used video
courses then i used practice exams and i
went through this whole cycle of doing
video courses then doing some practices
exams to check up on my knowledge and
what gaps i need to feel then going back
to those video courses re-watching some
of the videos and kind of continuing on
the cycle so for the video courses there
are two that i would like to recommend
so the first resource is adrian cantor's
solutions architect professional
certification video course so this video
course has a bunch of theory videos and
also hands-on labs and it really goes
above and beyond in terms of the level
of detail that it provides it teaches
you not only to pass the exam but also
teaches you the skills and the knowledge
to become a good essay so this course
was pretty interesting i didn't end up
doing the whole course because it was
very very long um and i wanted to focus
more time on practice questions instead
but i managed to get through a good
chunk of this course did a lot of
hands-on lap exercises and found it
really helpful in making me feel
confident in learning some of the
architectural patterns that might come
up for the exam i switched over to
another video course which is neil
davis's digital cloud training course
for the solutions architect professional
exam so this course was a lot more
concise it taught me exactly what was
needed for the exam and i also had a
really good amount of hands-on exercises
as well so that i could follow along and
gain a deeper knowledge
about each of the services and each of
the different sort of patterns that i'll
see whether that be traditional
three-tier architectures or serverless
web applications so in terms of practice
exams there's a whole bunch available
for free that you can find but what i
really liked about using paid resources
is that they have more detailed
explanations so when you get a question
wrong it really just tells you why you
got it wrong and why the correct answer
is the correct one so that's something i
really appreciated and the practice
question set that i really liked and i
used was tutorial dojos practice exams
because they had really in-depth
explanations when it came to those
questions and by doing a bunch of those
i was able to get more familiar with the
the format of the questions
and after doing that i was getting
some friends recommending me another set
of practice exams so i bought those as
well and did those those were neil
davis's digital cloud training practice
exams and
what i found good about these were that
it actually reflected some of the real
exam questions so when it came to me
doing the real exam a lot of the
questions seemed kind of you know i kind
of feel like i've done it before because
they were i think quite similar to some
of the questions that neil has put in
his practice exams so doing both of
those set of exams from both tutorials
dojo and digital cloud training really
set me up well when it came to setting
my real exam now let's talk about my
advice for actually preparing for the
exam the resources are really good but
when it comes down to actually
dedicating time the thing that's most
important is building consistency and
momentum when it comes to your study
it's really hard when we're working
full-time or we have other commitments
to really dedicate time consistently to
our aws journey and it can be quite
tempting to just say okay on the
weekends i'm just going to block out 10
hours and just going to study non-stop
but what works best for me and what i
recommend doing is to dedicate one to
two hours on a weekday actually
preparing for it and if you have time on
the weekend you can do a couple of hours
of study then and if not you can just
take the weekend off because you've done
some work already on the weekdays so
that's something i'll recommend trying
to build up consistency
my second piece of advice is that
practical experience is always more
important than theoretical knowledge so
make sure that you do all the hands-on
exercises provided by the video courses
rather than writing notes all the time
trying to memorize every single line and
every single feature of aws services
it's so much more important for you to
recognize patterns in architectures and
that way it's better for long-term
retention as well and it's better for
you when you actually want to become a
solutions architect in the future and
honestly i think my day-to-day work
really helped me with the solutions
arctic professional exam because i was
for example building a demo of a 3d web
application and through that i gained so
much knowledge about how 3d web apps
work and when it came to preparing for
the exam i found it so much more easier
to just understand the question of what
it was really asking as opposed to
trying to remember what i had memorized
from months ago okay finally let's talk
about exam strategy on the day what can
you do during those three hours to
maximize your chances of passing the
exam
so first of all i recommend something
called reverse flagging so you know when
you have a question that you're not sure
about you're flagging it that way i
think it doesn't really work for me what
i did was
i flagged the ones i was sure i got the
answer to so if i'm certain that the
answer is correct well i'm 90 sure that
as is correct i'll flag it and that way
i feel like every time i flag a question
it builds up my confidence rather than
every time i flag it i'm unsure and it
just shows myself that oh i need to
check back on it later so
by the end of the exam i would have
flags let's say 80 of the questions and
i will look back at the unflagged ones
to go back and
you know review the answer and try and
read over the question again something
else that i found to be quite useful was
to close my eyes for 10 to 20 seconds
every 10 to 20 minutes it sounds like
it's a waste of time because you only
have three hours for 75 questions but it
really helps for you to sort of regain
focus and just prevent eye strain during
the during the exam as well because
three hours looking at a screen it's
pretty pretty tough so
that's something i would recommend and
finally make sure you don't study on the
day of the exam there's already so much
that you've gained in the months or
weeks leading up to the exam i think on
the day if you try and grab more
information it might just overwhelm you
when it comes to the actual exam and you
want to be as relaxed as possible before
the exam actually starts
alright so this brings us to the end of
this video if you found it useful please
give this video a like leave your
comments and questions down below and
i'll see you next time best of luck for
your exam and bye for now